اهلا بكم الى الحصاد هذه كلمه استمعنا
اليها من قائد الانقلاب وقائد ما يسمي
نفسه المجلس الوطني لحمايه الوطن عبد
الرحمن في العاصمه نياميه في النيجر وقد
تحدث عن امور عده سنستعرضها ونناقشها
ونبدا مباشره من مراسلنا فينيامي بابا ولد
الحرمه بابا ربما كان يعني متوقعا ان يقول
شيئا ما هذا المساء وكانت لهجه تحد ولكن
في ذات الوقت انفتاح على الحوار
نعم عثمان بتحديد هو راوح زوج بين الامرين
هناك هذا الرفض والقاطع الحاسم الحازم
للتدخل العسكري الذي تلوح به منذ وصوله
الى السلطه في السادس والعشرين من يوليو
الماضي هناك هذا الترويح بان النيجر بان
جيش النيجر وان شعب النيجر سيتصدى لاي
تدخل عسكريا تقوم به الاكواس وهناك ايضا
هذا التممل وهذا الرفض وهذه الادانه التي
كررها الجدران عبد الرحمن الثاني وكانت
تاتي من قبل على لساني مسؤولين في المجلس
العسكري وفي الحكومه المعينه من طرفهم
وهذا الرفض وهذه الادانه لهذه العقوبات
التي يقول لنا النيجر من
المواد الغذائيه الاساسيه من الامدادات
الكهربائيه وكذلك من المواد الطبيه هناك
هذه الغصه التي طالما عبر عنها هؤلاء
القاده العسكريون من هذه العقوبات التي
فرضتها الاكواس التي يبدو ان بالفعل لها
تاثير كبير خاصه ياما نورنا الى الحاله
الاقتصاديه والمعيشيه العامه لشعبها
النيجر الذي يعيش نحو اربعين اكثر من
اربعين في المئه منه في فقر متقع وفق
ارقامي البنك الدولي وهناك ملايين
والاشخاص الذين يعيشون على مساعدات
وغوز دوليه هناك المحور الاخر البارز نعم
نعم فقط كنت اريد ان اقول هل نستطيع ان
نقول انما جاء في كلمه عبد الرحمن كياني
كان جديدا فيما يتعلق بالحوار والذي لم
يكتفي بالدعوه اليه ولكن تطرق الى تفاصيل
محدده وتوقيتات محدده ايضا
نعم بالتاكيد هذه التوقيتات وهذه هي
التفاصيل وهذه الاجال التي قدمها عبد
الرحمن الثاني تقدم لاول مره لكنها الحوار
منذ الايام الاولى خاصه بعد تعيين حكومه
محملا الامين الزين والوزير الاول محمد
الامين يتحدث عن الانفتاح على الحوار مع
الكواس عن كذلك اذا ما شاهدنا ايضا
الاعلام الرسمي في النيجر يتحدث عن
المرحله الانتقاليه يتحدث عن هذه اللقاءات
التي يعقدها محمد الامين زين وعدد من
المسؤولين في حكومته وكذلك اعضاء المجلس
العسكري الحاكم يتحدثون عن فتح افاقها
المرحله الانتقاليه دون تقديم التفاصيل
جديده لكن ما قدمه الجنرال عبد الرحمن
الثاني وبالفعل الجديد لكن هناك ايضا هذه
النقطه البارزه التي بالتاكيد اكد عليها
اكثر من مره وساق من اجلها غاصه من اجلها
في تاريخ النيجر وفي عراقي وفي شخصياته
تحدث عن الهبه التي سيواجه بها النيجريون
اي تدخل عسكري تحدث عن شخصيات من الفئه
العرقيه التي تعيش في النيجر عن عثمان عن
كوسم من الطوارق عن مختلفين العرقيات
وحاول ان يلعب على وتر هذه هذه العرقيات
المختلفه
ليقدمها بوصفها كتله موحده خلف المجلس
العسكري لابد ان نقول لتدخل محتمل
لابد ان نشير الى ان كلام الجنرال عبد
الرحمن تياني هذا ياتي في الوقت الذي
التقى فيه لاول مره وفد من اكواس بقياده
رئيس نيجيريا السابق عبد السلام ابو بكر
لاول مره التقى بعبر الجنرال عبد الرحمن
يعني ولاول مره التقى كذلك بالرئيس
المحتجز محمد بازوم
نعم بالتاكيد هذه الخطوه وهذا هذه ايضا
يمكن وصفها بخطوه انفتاحيه تجاه لكواس
نعلم انه بعد الايام الاولى من هذه
العقوبات وهذا الانقلاب كان هناك وفد
مشترك ما بين ليكواس والاتحاد الافريقي
والامم المتحده ابلغ السلطات العسكريه في
النيجر انه ينوي زيارتها من اجل النقاش
والحواري للخروج من الازمه التي يعيشها
النيجر لكن السلطات النيجر رفضت حينها
وبررت ذلك بانه خطوه تاتي ردا على اغلاق
الاجواء التي تقوم بها
ايضا لم تخطر في الوقت المناسب بهذه
الزياره اذا هذا الانفتاح وفي الحقيقه
خطوه يمكن وصفها بالانفتاحيه خاصه وان
مبعوثه تحدث عن لقائه مع بازون وقال انه
اطلع على وضعه صحي وكذلك استمع الى وجدته
نظره وانه سينقلها لرؤساء الدوليه قال
ايضا انه يرى ان هناك املا في الخروج من
هذه الازمه عن طريق الحوار
والنقاش وفق مقال من عاصمه النيجر بابا
ولد حرمه مراسل الجزيره شكرا لك
من ابو جين ضم الينا الدكتور كبير ادم
والباحث المختص في الشؤون الامنيه
والاستخباريه في منطقه الساحل الافريقي
دكتور ادم ما الذي يمكن ان نفهمه من كلام
الجنرال اعتياني منذ قليل عندما تحدث عن
الانفتاح على الحوار
ياخذ بالاعتبار سياده شعب النيجر وفي ذات
الوقت كانت هناك اللهجه تحد كبيره ضد اي
اعتداء محتمل على حد وصفه وقال انه سيواجه
باسود النيجر
[موسيقى]
الجنرال التياني دائما
استمر
بالحديث عن هذا الموقف هو تحدث عن الحوار
ولكنه يقوم بالامر المعاكس تماما اخر مره
قال هذا عندما هدد
بمحاكمه الرئيس المعزول محمد بازوم وهذا
لم يرق للاكواس رغم ان
اشتركت المجال المفتوح للحوار
ولكن افعاله صارت خلافا لما يقوله لذلك
لا تصدق كلامه عندما يتحدث عن هذه القضايا
ولذلك هو يقول شيئا ويفعل الشيء المناقض
بنسبه
لموقفه وخطته او الخطه المتوقعه من كرواس
هذا ما هو متوقعون من جنرال وهو يقول انه
مستعد لمواجهه اي عدوان ولكن الواقع هو ان
النيجر ليست في موقف
يخولها لمهاجمه او للرد على اي عدوان
عسكري في الوقت الحاضر
قال ان اللقاء الذي جمعه ببازوم وبيتيانى
يمكن ان يكون منطلقا للحوار هل ما تم حتى
الان مبشر من قبل قاده الانقلاب بالنسبه
لاكواس لانه يضعون الحل العسكري كخيار
اخير كما يؤكدون دائما
لا اعتقد ان اي احد في المنطقه يسعى الى
الحرب فالحرب لا تخدم المنطقه ابدا ولا
تخدموا
نيجيريا وهي الدوله القريبه المجاوره
للنيجر فهناك ما يتعلق بالتدخل العسكري
اذا من الجيد ان ايكرواس تضع هذا الخيار
كخيار اخير ولكن يجب ان لا يكون هناك شك
بان اقواس مستعده لتدخل عسكريا كما تعلمون
هناك ثلاث اجتماعات عقدت للتحضير لتدخل
العسكري اخرها كانت يوم الجمعه
في غانا وقد خرجوا
بقرار نتيجه هذه الاجتماعات ولكن يكفي
القول بانه لا احد يسعى الى الحرب ولكن
رغم هذا هي ما زالت خيارا
مطروح لدى اكواس الجنرال يتحدث عن حوار
يشارك فيه كافه فئات الشعب في مده اقصاها
ثلاث سنوات
هل تعتقد ان اكواس قادره على الانتظار
بثلاث سنوات وهل يمكن ان يكون هذا
حلا مقبولا وليس الاصرار على ضروره عوده
الرئيس المحتجز محمد بازو
منذ السادس والعشرين من يوليو عندما حصل
الانقلاب في النيجر كانت متسقه بان في
قولها بانها لا تريد ان تناقش وتتناقش مع
الجنرال فهي لا تعترف به
اصرت على انه يجب ان يعيد السلطه للرئيس
بازوم ولكن اعتقد ان
الاتفاق العام قد لا يكون عقلانيا في
اعاده السلطه الى الرئيس بازون
والنظر في مرحله انتقال لثلاثه اعوام هذا
امر غير وارد ولكن الولايات المتحده على
سبيل المثال
قامت بارسال سفيره الى النيجر والولايات
المتحده تقول انها مستعده
لمناقشه عمليه انتقاليه دبلوماسيه يبدو
بان صوت العالمي
بالنسبه لاعاده
السلطه الى بازون هو ليس متسقا ولذلك ربما
عمليه انتقاليه اقل من ثلاثه اعوام وربما
ان
لا يكون هناك قياده يعني قد يكون امرا
منطقيا يمكن ان يكون هناك وجود لحكم فيه
عسكريون وفيه مدنيون اذا قد يحدث هذا
الامر وقد يكون مقبولا للمجتمع الدولي اذا
ربما مجلس انتقالي يرتب الانتخابات هذا
امر حدث كما راينا في النيجر في السابق
اذا فهذا الامر ايضا ممكن الباحث المختص
في الشؤون الامنيه والاستخباريه في منطقه
الساحل الافريقي من عاصمه نيجيريا
الدكتور كبير ادم وشكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
الى التطورات في الاراضي الفلسطينيه حيث
اعلن الجيش الاسرائيلي مقتل اسرائيليين
اثنين في عمليه اطلاق نار في بلده حواره
في الضفه الغربيه وعرضت القناه الحاديه
عشره الاسرائيليه تسجيلا مصورا من كاميرا
مثبته في محطه لغسل السيارات في حواره
جنوبيه نابلس شهدت مقتله اسرائيليين اثنين
في اطلاق نار وقالت القناه ان هذا التسجيل
يوثق العمليه
هذا وقال المتحدث باسم الجيش الاسرائيلي
ان رئيس الاركان ليفي تفقد مكان العمليه
واجرى تقييما للوضع الامني واستعرض انتشار
القوات ونصب الحواجز في المنطقه بالاضافه
الى الجهود الاستخباريه للقبض على منفذ
العمليه وقالها الحديثه عن هجوم تخريبي
امر صعب وان القوات الاسرائيليه تعمل على
ملاحقه منفذ العمليه
وقد وسع جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي نطاق
مداهماته وتنشيطه في القرى المحيطه بحواره
جنوب نابلس وذكر مواطنون فلسطينيون ان
قوات الاحتلال تشن حمله اعتقالات وتمشيط
ومداهمات في قرى عريف ومادما وبيتا وانها
احكمت اغلاقها لبلده حواره كما عزز جيش
الاحتلال حواجزه في الضفه الغربيه وتحديدا
في محيط النابلس ونشر دوريات ونصب مزيدا
من الحواجز العسكريه وصدرت دعوات فلسطينيه
تحذر من وقوع اعتداءات من قبل المستوطنين
خلال الساعات المقبله
التي وقعت في هذه المغسله تحديدا واعتبرت
فلسطينيا بانها الاكثر جراه وشجاعه
واسرائيليا بانها شكلت فشلا امنيا وعسكريا
ذريعا ادت الى مقتل اسرائيليين المنفذ وصل
الى هنا قام باطلاق النار من مسافه صفر
على اسرائيليين اثنين بالطبع المنفذ تمكن
من الفرار قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي من
كافه الاذرع الامنيه تجري واجرت تحقيقات
على مدار ساعات للوصول الى المنفذ الذي
قام وتمكن من تغيير ملابسه في هذا الحقل
تحديدا حيث عثر جنود الاحتلال على قميصه
وايضا تم العثور على المسدس الذي استخدمه
في هذه
العمليه قاده الجيش
الاسرائيلي وعلى راسهم رئيس هيئه الاركان
تحديدا الذي اجرى تقييما هنا على الارض
طالبت قاده المستوطنين بمنعهم من الوصول
الى القرى الفلسطينيه ومهاجمه الاهالي ليس
لحمايه الفلسطينيين من عمليات انتقام بل
لتمكين الجيش من مواصله التحقيق للوصول
الى المنفذ
جزيره من بلده حواره جنوب نابلس
المكان بلده حواره جنوبيه محافظه نابلس
شماليه الضفه الغربيه المحتله وتحديدا
اكثر داخل احدى محطات غسيل السيارات
الواقعه على الشارع الرئيسي الذي يربط
محافظتين نابلس ورام الله واثناء وجودهم
مستوطنين داخل المحطه وصل احد الفلسطينيين
المكان رجلا وبعد تاكده من هويتهما اخرج
مسدسه واطلق النار عليهما من مسافه قصيره
وانسحب مباشره من المكان كان الحديث في
البدايه عن اصابات بليغه لاحقت
بالمستوطنين قبل ان يؤكد مقتلوهما دفع جيش
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي بتعزيزات كبيره الى
المكان وبدا بنصب الحواجز على الشوارع
المؤديه الى حواره بحثا عن المنفذ كما
اقتحم بلدتي بيتا وعورت المجاورتين سبق
للبلده الصغيره التي يقطنها نحو 7 فلسطيني
ولا تزيد مساحتها على عشره الاف دونم ان
قفزت الى واجهه الاحداث في الضفه الغربيه
في ظل حمله تصعيد اسرائيليه لم تتوقف منذ
بدايه العام فوقعها بالقرب من تجمعات
استيطانيه كبرى سبق انهاشت الاف الدنمات
من اراضيها مثل مستوطنات يتسهار والوان
موري وجفعات رنين جعلها هدفا لاعتداءات
واقتحامات متكرره من مجموعات استيطانيه
متطرفه خصوصا المعروفه باسم شبيبه التلال
والمنتميته للصهيونيه الدينيه المتشدده
بلغت ذروه الاعتداءات نهايه فبراير الماضي
فبعد عمليه فلسطينيه اسفرت عن مقتل
مستوطنين شنت مجموعه كبيره من المستوطنين
هجوما واسعا على حواره على مراه من الجيش
الاسرائيلي وحرقت عشرات المنازل والسيارات
والمحالي التجاريه وتباهت بذلك عبر اغنيه
تحدثت عن وقائع ذلك الاعتداء
[موسيقى]
بل ان وزير الماليه
سبق ان دعا علنا الى محو بلده حواره من
الوجود
وفي ردود الفعل باركت حركه حماس عمليه
اطلاق النار في حواره وقال الناطق باسم
الحركه عبد اللطيف القنوع انها نتاج وعد
المقاومه الثابت والمستمر بالدفاع عن
الشعب الفلسطيني والرد على جرائم الاحتلال
وحمايه المسجد الاقصى واكد القنوع ان
ضربات المقاومه ستبقى متواصله وممتده
لتطال جيش الاحتلال والمستوطنين وتفشل
مخطط حكومه الاحتلال لبناء الهيكل المزعوم
من جهته قال المتحدث باسم حركه الجهاد
طارق سلمي للجزيره ان المقاومه تبعث رساله
للحكومه الاسرائيليه بان سن القوانين
واطلاق التهديدات لن يغير معادلاتها
رساله للحكومه الاسرائيليه
الاسرائيلي بان فن القوانين
التهديدات لن تغير شيء في ارض الواقع وفي
المعادلات التي فرضتها المقاومه
الفلسطينيه ان المقاومه اليوم لا يمكن لها
ان تستسلم ولا يمكن لها ان تتراجع ولا
يمكن لها ان تلقي السلاح ولذلك هي توصل
رساله للحكومه الفاشيه لان ما يجري في
الداخل الاسرائيلي لن يكون
للوصول لاغضاء الجمهور الاسرائيلي وهذه
العمليه هي رساله ميدانيه بان الشعب
الفلسطيني مستمر في الجهاد وفي المقاومه
العمليات فتتصاعد بشكل اكبر واكثر لالام
العدو وللجمه
معنى من رام الله مصطفى البرغوثي الامين
العام للمبادره الوطنيه الفلسطينيه دكتور
مصطفى يقول الفلسطينيون ان هذه رساله بان
المقاومه مستمره ولكن هل يفهم
الاسرائيليون هذه الرساله برايك
يفهمونها بالطريقه الصعبه وليس بالطرق
السهله ما يجري هو يؤكد ثلاثه امور الامر
الاول ان المقاومه الفلسطينيه هي الرد على
السياسه الاسرائيليه الاجراميه التي وصلت
الى حد اغتيال 229 فلسطيني منذ بدايه هذا
العام وحده ومنهم 38 طفل وشن اعتداءات
واعتقالات بالالاف ضد الفلسطينيين واكثر
من ذلك السياسه المعلنه بانهم ينوون حسم
الصراع بالضم والتهويد والتطهير العرقي
وارهاب المستوطنين بالتالي الرساله
الفلسطينيه واضحه المقاومه هي الرد على ما
يقوم به هؤلاء المستعمرون من اعتداءات
وبعضها يجري الان في منطقه بيتين ومنطقه
حاجز بيت ايل مستعمره بيتئيل وحتى على
حواره نفسها هذا الذي يجري رد على القمع
الاسرائيلي وتاكيد بامر مهم جدا ثاني وهو
ان القمع والتنكيل والقتل والخطط العسكريه
الاسرائيليه فشلت وستبقى تفشل في كسر او
وقف المقاومه الفلسطينيه ويفشل معها او
تفشل معها النظريه الاسرائيليه بضروره
توفير مئه بالمئه امن للاسرائيليين وصفر
بالمئه امن للفلسطينيين لن يكون امن ولا
سلام للاسرائيليين ما دام الفلسطينيون
محرومون من الامن ومحرومون من الاحتلال
ومحرومون بالاضطهاد العنصري الذي يمثل
النظام الابرتايد ولكن هناك نقطه ثالثه
مهمه جدا
اعتقد ان بعض الاسرائيليين بداوا يفهمونها
على الاقل بعض الصحفيين ويكتبون عنها ان
القناعه تعمقت لدى الشعب الفلسطيني باسره
بانه اسرائيل لا تفهم الا لغه القوه ولا
حل سوى المقاومه والكفاح وهذا بالذات ما
يؤمن به جيل الشباب الفلسطيني اليوم والذي
يتولى في الواقع المهمه الاكبر بمقاومه
الاحتلال ومقاومه نظام الابر هل هناك
اعتقاد بان الاسرائيليين سوف يتوقفون عن
ما يمارسونه في الضفه الغربيه بسبب هذه
العمليات يعني الفلسطينيون يقومون بهذا من
باب الواجب ام هناك قناعه بانه يمكن وقف
هذا النهج الاسرائيلي في الضفه الغربيه
لا هناك طبعا جانبين للامر الجانب الاول
طبعا نحن نحذر من ردود الفعل ايضا
الاسرائيليه ومن هجمات المستوطنين الان
المستوطنين في اظهاريو يخططون لهجمات
واسعه ضد الفلسطينيين ويجب الحذر من ذلك
هذا شيء مفهوم ولكن ما يجري فلسطينيا ليس
فقط رد فعل على الاعتداءات الاسرائيليه بل
اكثر من ذلك هو استراتيجيه وطنيه كفاحيه
مقاومه بديله لنهج المفاوضات التي فشل
والذي اغلقت اسرائيل ابوابه بالكامل هي
استراتيجيه وطنيه كفاحيه تؤمن بانه الحل
لن يكون الا بتغيير ميزان القوى ولن يكون
تغيير ميزان القوى الا بالمقاومه والكفاح
والصمود على الارض
والتوحيد الصف الوطني على نهج واستراتيجيه
وطنيه كفاحيه مقاومه والتصدي لمخطط
سمودريتش
بتصفيه القضيه الفلسطينيه سواء بالقمع
والتنكيل او بالتطبيع الذي يجري ليس
مقاومه مجرد رد وليس مقاومه معزوله عن
الاشياء الاخرى هي جزء من نهج واستراتيجيه
يؤمن بها الشعب الفلسطيني بانه ما حك جلدك
مثل ظفرك ولا حل سوى المقاومه والكفاح
للتصدي لكل هذا الاجرام والاهم للتصدي
لمحاوله تهويد وضم كل فلسطين كما تخطط
الحركه الصهيونيه مصطفى البرغوث الامين
العام للمبادره الوطنيه الفلسطينيه شكرا
لك دكتور مصطفى
وينضم الينا من الناصره وديع عواوده
الباحثه المختص في الشان الاسرائيلي سيد
وديع عواوده اذا ما بدانا من نقطه انه
المنفذ لم يتم العثور عليه حتى الان ربما
هذا يميز هذه العمليه عن عمليات سابقه
لا بطبيعه الحال كانت العمليات السابقه
بمعظمها قد تاخرت عمليه القاء القبض على
منفذيها خاصه
لساعات وليس اكثر ربما ايام وربما في
اسابيع ولكن
لم نسمع حتى اي معلومات عاده يقال انه جاء
من يرجح انه جاء من المنطقه الفلانيه من
الخليل من منطقه ما يعني لكن هذه المره لا
نسمع اي شيء عن المنفذ
نعم هناك تلميحات اسرائيليه غليظه في
الساعات الاخيره ان هويه المنفذ معروفه
خاصه انه كان سافر الوجه والقى بسلاحه وهو
في طريق الانسحاب وخاصه ان الاستخبارات
العسكريه تستخدم الكثير من التقنيات وتلك
منها التي يعني لم يعلن عنها بالكامل
تقنيه تتعلق بقراءه ملامح الوجه وغيرها من
الكاميرات الحراسه في الشوارع هذه يعني
ليست
المره الاولى ولا العشره هذا بالمناسبه
العمليه العاشره في حواره
وفي معظم الحالات كان منفذوها من خارج
حواره وكما قال الاستاذ مصطفى البرغوثي
يعني رغم الاعتقالات المتكرره للمنفذين او
تصفيه المنفذين
تتواصل عمليه المقاومه الفلسطينيه لكنني
اختلف مع مصطفى البرغوثي وهو يتحدث عن
استراتيجيه مقاومه
لا توجد هناك استراتيجيات مقاومه لفسائر
الفلسطينيه غير موجوده كما كانت في الماضي
لا مجال للمقارنه معظم العمليات التي تتم
تتم على خلفيه يعني
مبادره فرديه لهذا او ذاك من شباب
المقاومه وخصم في بعض البؤر في كثير من
مساحات الضفه الغربيه هناك حاله من الهدوء
انما بعض البؤر بعض المناطق التي تشهد في
هذه العمليات وربما هذا يعني لكن كما ذكرت
هناك العمليه الاخرى عمليات متتاليه اسمعك
وعمليات متتاليه وحواره وحدها يعني كانت
فيها ربما عشر عمليات او شيء من هذا النوع
مختص في الشؤون الاسرائيليه كيف يفهم هذا
لدى الاسرائيليين
نعم لا شك ان ارتفاع وتيره المقاومه داخل
الاراضي الفلسطينيه المحتله تدفع رغم انف
الاسرائيليين القضيه الفلسطينيه على
الواجهه رغم محاولات من كل الاطراف طمسها
والانشغال في قضايا داخليه ومحاوله
التعامل عنها حتى قبل يعني اندلاع
السجلات الداخليه في اسرائيل كانت هناك
اوساط واسعه جدا في اسرائيل تحاول ان
تتحاشى الاحتلال والقضيه الفلسطينيه حينما
تاتي مثل هذه العمليات بالطبع تطفو على
السطح خاصه حينما يتكون الاثمان تتعلق
بعسكريين جنود او تتعلق بمستوطنين وهذا
ربما ايضا له علاقه في الحديث عن ضروره ان
يرتب الفلسطينيون ايضا اوراقهم وعدم
الرهان فقط على هذا الانشغال اسرائيل
الداخلي او على هذا النزيف الاسرائيلي
الداخلي بمعنى ان هناك حاجه بالاضافه الى
المقاومه للبندقيه الى عقل سياسي يرتب
الفلسطينيون انفسهم ماذا يريدون كيف
يفعلون وهل لديهم شركاء في العالم وهل
بالامكان تجنيد اوساط في الراي العام
الاسرائيلي لان مثل هذه الاثمان لم يعد
نعم اكيد يعني هدف في المشهد الكبير لابد
من عقل السياسي ولكن هناك ممارسات
اسرائيليه في هذه المستوطنات والتوسع
الاستيطاني وما الى ذلك وهناك هذه
العمليات الفلسطينيه في المقابل فكيف
برايك يمكن ان تؤثر على السياسه
الاسرائيليه في ظل تنامي وسيطره اليمين
المتشدد ايضا في هذه الاونه
للاسف يعني انا اقول بهذه العزاله اننا
ذاهبون الى مرحله في غايه الصعوبه وغايه
الخطوره ولا استبعد اننا على عتبه مرحله
بلكانيه بل كانت الصراع بمعنى دخول
الاراضي الفلسطينيه من البحر الى النهر في
مرحله نوع من الحرب الاهليه ان شئت بين
مزدوجين على شاكله ما جرى في البلقان في
اوروبا الشرقيه نتيجه ازدياد عدد الشعبين
هناك نحو خمسه عشر مليون في بقعه صغيره
يزداد عدد المستوطنين تزداد رقعه
المستوطنات
تضيق المساحه الفلسطينيه التي تخضع
للاراده الفلسطينيه والقران الفلسطيني
الاحتكاك يزيد وهناك تطاول على المسجد
الاقصى الاجواء مشبعه بالبنزين ولذلك يعني
وجود مثل هذه المجموعه من الغيبيين
والوزراء الارهابيين المدنين بالارهاب
داخل الحكومات داخل المحاكم اسرائيليه
ينذر بان الصراع خاصه على العتبه خطيره
جدا خاصه وان هناك تغيرات ايضا حتميه في
الساحه الفلسطينيه من ناحيه السياسيه وانا
اشير يعني اشير بذلك الى مرحله ما بعد
الرئيس عباس لان هناك تساؤلات عن مدى
شرعيه خليفه الرئيس عباس وقدرته على بسط
نفوذه وارادته في ظل انشغال العالم في
كثير من القضايا شكرا جزيلا من الناصره
وديعه وعوداء الباحث المختص في الشؤون
الاسرائيليه
[موسيقى]
في اوكرانيا تشهد جبهات الشمال الشرقيه
تصعيدا كبيرا خصوصا في مقاطعه خاركيف حيث
وصفت نائبه وزير الدفاع الاوكراني هنا
مليار الاوضاع في كوبيان بالصعبه وقالت ان
القوات الروسيه تهاجم كوبيانسك في محاوله
منها للسيطره على المدينه التي تعتبر نقطه
مواصلات رئيسيه ومركزا للهجوم الروسي في
الشرق كما اعلنت هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه
تعرض تعرض مناطق واسعه من البلاد لعشرات
الصواريخ والغارات خلال الساعات الماضيه
واعلنت وزاره الداخليه الاوكرانيه مقتل
سبعه اشخاص واصابه 129 بينهم احد عشر طفلا
في قصف روسيا استهدف مدينه تشيرنيف
الشماليه اوكرانيا ووفقا لمصادر طبيه فان
معظم الضحايا سقطوا عند موقف للحافلات في
الساحه الرئيسيه
ونشر الرئيس الاوكراني فلودي صورا قال
انها للقصف الروسي على وسط مدينه شرنيف
وعلق زيلينسكي بالقول ان الصاروخ الروسي
استهدف وسط المدينه وحول يومه الى يوم الم
وخساره وفق تعبيره
تطورات الحرب في اوكرانيا تفرض انعكاسات
على الداخل الروسي حيث اعلنت وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه احباط هجوم بطائرات مسيره على
مقاطعه موسكو كما اكدت الوزاره اصابه
طائره عسكريه جراء هجوم اوكرانيا اخر
بمسيره على مطار عسكري في مقاطعه نوفوورد
شمال العاصمه
لاوكرانيا يد طويله باتت تمتد الى عمق
الاراضي الروسيه فتضرب اهدافا في موسكو
ومناطق اخرى كما تستهدف مطارات عسكريه
وقواعد واهدافا حيويه روسيه وحتى الكرملين
انها المسيرات الاوكرانيه من احداثها
استهداف مطار نوفورود ورغم اشاره الروايه
الروسيه في التصدي للمسيرات الاوكرانيه
المهاجمه للمطار ذكرت في الوقت نفسه ان
طائره عسكريه روسيه اصيبت جراء الهجوم
الذي نتج عنه ايضا حريق في احد المدارج
هذه الحادثه وغيرها تثير التساؤل بشان
فعاليه انظمه الدفاع الجوي الروسيه من
رادارات ومنظومات تصدى
في نيسان ابريل الماضي تحدث نائب القائد
العام لقوات الفضاء الروسيه الى صحيفه
روسيه مشيرا الى ان قواتهم واجهه تحديات
فرضتها الضربات الاوكرانيه وان بلاده تخطط
لاصلاح قوات دفاعها الجوي بعد اكتساب خبره
جديده ولمواجهه انضمام فنلندا الى النيتو
بالارقام تحدث الجنرال الروسي عن اضافه 50
محطه رادار متنقله وطائره انذار مبكر من
طراز اي 50 تعمل على مدى 24 ساعه وتكثيف
انتاج نظام ار ال كي ام سي المضاده
للمسيرات لكن رغم هذا التكثيف وفق المسؤول
العسكري الروسي فان الواقع يشير الى ان
نسق الضربات الاوكرانيه وارتفاع مستوى
تهديدها ظلاف ازدياد بالنظر الى التقارب
الزمني وطبيعه ما يستهدف داخل الاراضي
الروسيه تمتلك روسيا منظومات دفاع جوي
عديده ابرزها منظومات
وهي منظومات قريبه ومتوسطه المدى وقادره
على ضرب اكثر من هدف في وقت واحد مثل
الطائرات والمروحيات والمسيرات وحتى
الصواريخ
وهناك منظومات دفاع جوي بعيد المدى ابرزها
اس بارقامها التصاعديه من 200 الى 300
واربع مئه واحدثها اس 500 حتى الان يبدو
محدودا ما تحدثه هجمات المسيرات
الاوكرانيه من اضرار وفق الروايه الروسيه
لكن الثابته انه يفرض تحديا حقيقيا امام
الجيش الروسي فمع تكثيف الاوكرانيين
لاستخدام سلاح المسيرات تتوسع امام القوات
الروسيه جبهه الحرب وتثقل مسؤوليه الحمايه
والدفاع في الجبهات وداخل روسيا نفسها
وفيما يبدو تعقيبا على المشهد قال ديمتري
ميدفي نائب رئيس مجلس الامن الروسي ان
الحرب لن تتوقف قبل تفكيك اوكرانيا
الحاليه كدوله وان استغرق الامر سنوات او
عقودا واضاف في تصريحات عبر منصه تيليجرام
انه لا خيار امام بلاده فاما تدمير نظام
كييف او سينتهي الامر بتمزيق روسيا حسب
تعبيره كما قال المسؤول الروسي ان الحرب
في اوكرانيا مكلفه للغرب وغير ضروريه وان
الغرب لن يواصل دعم كييف الى الحد الذي
يضر بمصالحه
من بيروت معنا العميد الياس حنا الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي ست العميد اذا ما
علقنا على كلام هل يمكن لهذه الحرب بالفعل
ان تستمر عقودا
لا نتحدث عن العقود ولكن الاكيد ان هذه
الحرب لن تنتهي عثمان هذه السنه والدليل
على ذلك ان الفريقان يتحضران للمرحله
القادمه
زياده الانتاج العسكري الروسي
التطويع المزيد ومنهم من يقول ان بامكانيه
روسيه 2.4 مليون من الجنود ولا نزل في
المرحله العسكريه التي لم تحسم بعد يعني
لم نصل الى مرحله قد يذهب او يقتنع
الطرفان بالذهاب الى طاوله
التفاوت حتى الامريكيون يقولون انه لن
نذهب الى طاوله تفاوض الا بموافقه
اوكرانيه وهذا الامر ليس متوفرا ولكن ما
قاله الرئيس مداف هو فعلا يعكس ما يريد
ويقول الرئيس بوتين ولكن كيف يمكن ان
يقتنع الطرفان بان يذهب الى طاوله
المفاوضات ان كان كل ما حدث خاصه على
الجانب الاوكراني لم يقنعهما بان يذهب الى
طاوله
يعني ما الذي يمكن ان يحدث عسكريا اكثر
مما حدث
يعني قد يذهب الاوكراني الى ضرب الجسر
البري وهذا امر مستبعد حاليا بناء لما
نشرته ان الاستخبارات الامريكيه تقول من
الصعب الوصول حتى الى مليتو بول فاذا
اليوم هذا امر مهم اثنين الاستنزاف عثمان
شيء مهم جدا يعني اليوم الجيش الروسي
مستنزف العتاد الروسي مستنزف وفي نفس
الوقت العتاد الغربي بالرغم من حداثته لا
يكفي كي تحقق اوكرانيا
ما تريد ان تحققه على الاقل الخرق او على
الاقل تحرير الارض الاوكرانيه قد نصل الى
مرحله ما يسمى بستيل ميت وقد نصل الى
النموذج الكوري على ان تكون هناك ليس وقت
للحرب ستيل ميت او وقف للنار لفتره طويله
وعليه تبدا حلول سياسيه على المدى الطويل
اوكرانيا ترسل مسيراتها الى موسكو وسبق
وان وصفت هذه الضربات بانها
سيكولوجيه او رمزيه او يمكن ان يكون لها
تاثير نفسي ولكن سؤالي هل يمكن ان يتطور
الامر اكثر من ذلك هل لدى اوكرانيا القدره
على ان تطور قدراته العسكريه بما تحمله
بما تحمله من ارث او بما ورثته حتى عن عن
روسيا نفسها من قدرات في الجانب العسكري
عثمان 200 شركه كانت ايام الاتحاد
السوفيتي تزود روسيا بالعتاد العسكري
اوكرانيا كانت تزود قبل الحرب بالتسعينات
ما بعدها الصين حتى بالعتاد العسكري لديهم
ما يقارب 375 الف من المبرمجين يعني لدى
اوكرانيا صناعات عسكريه متقدمه محركات
الطوافات حتى
البارجه موسكو التي اغلقت هي بنيت في
مايكوليف ومؤخرا تم قصف معمل سيرش العسكري
للمحركات
وهو الذي يزود الطائرات المسيرات التركيه
بالمحركات فاذا نحن امام مرحله قادره على
صنعنا المرحله القاعده العلميه موجوده
والقاعده الصفط وير كما يقال ايضا موجوده
ولكن هذا امر يتطلب وقت ان يتطلب الاعداد
التخطيط التجربه ومن ثم
الانتاج الكثير والاستعمال وهذا امر يتطلب
وقت عثمان من بيروت العميد الياس حنا
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي شكرا جزيلا
لك
[موسيقى]
قال متحدث باسم الجيش السوداني الى الفرقه
الخامسه عشره في الجيش تصدت لمحاولات عده
من قوات الدعم السريع للتقدم نحو مدينه
نيالا في جنوب دارفور ومن جهه ثانيه اعلن
الجيش ان طائرات المسيره قصفت اهدافا
للدعم السريع وسط الخرطوم بينما جرت
اشتباكات وسط ام درمان وفي التداعيات
الانسانيه اعلنت منظمه اليونيسف حاجتها
العاجله الى 400 مليون دولار لدعم تسعه
ملايين من الاطفال الاكثر ضعفا في السودان
وذلك وسط الظروف الحرب القاسيه التي
يواجهها العاملون في المجال الانساني
يتسع نطاق القتال بين الجيش السوداني
وقوات الدعم السريع يوما بعد الاخر
وتتزايد انعكاساته السالبه في الخرطوم
وغيرها من ولايات البلاد
اعلن الجيش ان الطائرات المسيره قصفت
مواقع الدعم السريع وسط الخرطوم في محيط
السوق العربي القريب من القصر الرئاسي
وكان من ضمن الاهداف بناء يستخدمه الدعم
كمخزن للذخيره بينما جرت اشتباكات
بالاسلحه الثقيله والخفيفه بين الجانبين
وسط ام درمان في هذه الاثناء تستمر معارك
الجانبين العنيفه في مدينه نيالا كبرى مدن
جنوب دارفور مما احدث اضرارا كبيره في
بنيه المدينه والاحياء السكنيه وادى لفرار
الالاف من السكان ويؤكد المسؤولون ان
المدينه تعيش اوضاعا انسانيه كارثيه
تجاوزت الان كل حدود التوقع
منذ اندلاع قتال الجيش السوداني وقوات
الدعم السريعه في منتصف ابريل الماضي شهد
اقليم دارفور اعمال عنف تعد الاسوا واثرت
بشكل كبير على عواصم ولايات الاقليم الخمس
التي كانت ملاذا للفارين من القتال
وتداعياته واصبح الالاف الذين فروا اليها
يفرون منها الان منظمه الامم المتحده
لرعايه الطفوله
اعلنت حاجتها العاجله الى 400 مليون دولار
لتقديم المساعدات المنقذه للحياه الى تسعه
ملايين طفل هم في امس الحاجه اليها وتشير
التقديرات الامم المتحده الى ان النسبه
انعدام الامن الغذائي تتضاعف في السودان
منذ ماي الماضي مما اثر على نحو 25 مليون
شخص يحتاجون الان الى اغاثه عاجله يمكن ان
تمنع ظروف الحرب وصولها حتى لو توفرت
فالعاملون في مجال الاغاثه بالسودان يواجه
الخطر الذي يواجهه المدنيون مع استمرار
الاشتباكات المسلحه وسقط منهم عشرات
القتلى والجرعه ويصف مكتب تنسيق الشؤون
الانسانيه تابعوا للمنظمه الدوليه السودان
بانه من اكثر الاماكن خطوره وصعوبه على
العاملين في المجال الانساني وان عشرات
المرافق ومستودعات المساعدات جرى الاعتداء
عليها ونهبها وتبدو خطوره انعكاسات ذلك
بوضوح بقراءه تقرير الامم المتحده الصادر
بمناسبه اليوم العالمي للعمل الانساني
والذي يقول ان السودان يحتل المرتبه
الثانيه عالميا بين الدول الاكثر خطوره
على العاملين في الحقل الانساني
[موسيقى]
نعود الى التطورات المتلاحقه في النيجر
فمنذ اللحظه الاولى للانقلاب العسكري وحتى
الان لازمت الموقف الامريكي اولويه الجهود
الدبلوماسيه وعوده الرئيس المنتخب محمد
بازوم الى السلطه لحل الازمه التي تعصف
بمنطقه غرب افريقيا دعا الرئيس جو بايدن
في الثالث من اغسطس الجاري للافراج الفوري
عن الرئيس بازوم المحتجز مع عائلته من قبل
قاده الانقلاب مشددا على اهميه الدفاع عن
القيم الديمقراطيه وفي اطار الجهود
الدبلوماسيه الامريكيه لعوده النظام
الدستوري قامت فيكتوريا نولاندا القائمه
باعمال نائب وزير الخارجيه الامريكي في
السابع من اغسطس الجاري بزياره بنيامين
واجرت محادثات مع بعض قاده الانقلاب لكن
زياره لم تنجح والمحادثات وصفت بالصعبه
للغايه
وقبل طلبها بلقاء طلبها لقاء الرئيس
المحتجز محمد بازوم وقائد الانقلاب عبد
الرحمن كياني بالرفض من جهه ذكر وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي للصحفيين في الخامس عشر
من الشهر الجاري ان بلاده لا تزال تركز
بشده على الدبلوماسيه لتحقيق النتائج التي
تريدها اي عوده النظام الدستوري كما تحدث
حينها عن استمرار وجود مساحه للدبلوماسيه
لتحقيق ذلك وترفض اداره الرئيس جو بايدن
وصفه اطاحه الجيش برئيس النيجر بانها
انقلاب لان من شان هذا التوصيف انهاء
المساعدات الامنيه الامريكيه والتدريب
وربما المساعدات العسكريه وفقا للقانون
الامريكي
لم تقل الاداره الامريكيه هل ستوفر
الخدمات اللوجستيه او اي دعم لتدخل اكواس
العسكري وحرصت دائما على ان يكون التدخل
العسكري ضد الانقلابيين الملاذ الاخير كما
يوصف وقد قالت الخارجيه الامريكيه ان وصول
سفيرتها الجديده كافلان
في هذا السياق المضطرب هو لتسريع الوصول
الى حل سياسي وذلك بناء على توجيه من وزير
الخارجيه انت
واوضحت الخارجيه في بياننا ان سفيره
واشنطن الى النيجر لن تقدم اوراق اعتمادها
في الوقت الراهن بسبب الازمه الحاليه تم
اقتراح اسم الدفرماسيه الامريكيه في مارس
2023 ووافق الكونغرس على تعيينها يوم
السابع والعشرين من يوليو اي بعد يوم واحد
من الانقلاب العسكري في النيجر واحتجاز
الرئيس محمد بازون وكيف عضو في السلك
الدبلوماسيه الامريكي وسبق لها انشغلت
منصبه نائب رئيس البع ثه في سفاره
الولايات المتحده في ابوجا في نيجيريا
وقبل ذلك كانت رئيسه قسم غرب وجنوب
افريقيا ثم مديره مكتب التحرير الافريقي
في مكتب الاستخبارات والبحوث في وزاره
الخارجيه الامريكيه
دي مناقشه ما يحدث الان في النيجر من خلال
الموقف الامريكي هناك تنضم الينا من
واشنطن بيسا ويليامز وهي السفيره
الامريكيه السابقه في النيجر اهلا وسهلا
بك لك زميله الان
ذهبت الى النيجر لكنها لم تقدم اوراق
اعتماد ماذا ستكون مهمتها الدبلوماسيه في
هذه المرحله الع
اصمهم مساء السفيره امامها مهمه بان
تتواصل مع سفارتنا لكي يكون هناك ضمان
بوجود قياده هناك وواضح بان الحكومه
الامريكيه تريد منها ان تتواصل
مع الرئيس بازون وتتحدث الي ولكنه هناك
ايضا
كامريكيه رفيعه المستوى تمثل الحكومه
الامريكيه
لدى المجلس العسكري الحالي كما شئتم ان
تسموه وذلك للحديث اليهم
نعم الان ما اهميه النيجر بالنسبه
للولايات المتحده الامريكيه ما هي
المحددات التي سوف تحدد الخطوات التي
ستتخذها امريكا في النيجر في المرحله
المقبله
كما تعلمون هذا سؤال مهم جدا ان يجريون
كانوا اصدقاء وثيقين للولايات المتحده
لمده من الزمن الان
ولقد كان بيننا تعاون وثيق
في المجال الاقتصادي والمجال المساعدات
الامنيه وفي القانون
وايضا المجتمع المدني هناك كان فاعلا
ونشطا هذا الانقلاب حسب اعتقادي وضع كل
شيء قيد التعليق
يعود الامر لهذه الاداره الامريكيه ان
تحدد معالم العلاقه مع النيجر في المستقبل
القريب بما انك كنت سفيره هناك
بما انك كنت سفيره هناك فربما تكونين افضل
من يمكن الاجابه على هذا السؤال ما هي
المصالح الامريكيه في النيجر سواء كانت
مصالح اقتصاديه او سياسيه او غيرها ما هي
بالتحديد
الولايات المتحده كان لها علاقه منفتحه
جدا مع افريقيا جنوب الصحراء كبدايه في
النيجر النيجر كان لها تاريخ لافت منذ
2010 عندما كان هناك انقلاب
للابقاء على النظام الدستوري ومن ثم
الانتخاب
الديمقراطيه بالاضافه الى الانتقال
الدستوري لرئيس بازون اذا على مدى 15 عاما
الولايات المتحده كانت تعمل بجديه لاظهار
باننا نريد ان نقدم الدعم للديمقراطيه في
افريقيا وانا نريد ايضا ان نساعد
الشركاء الافريقيين الافارقه ونتعاون معهم
في الامن في غرب افريقيا وهذا امر مهم
الولايات المتحده وقد وضحنا هذا من خلال
كل تفاعلاتنا مع الحكومه النيجيريه ومع
الشعب ايضا في افريقيا بالحديث اليهم في
تلك المنطقه لذلك اعتقد اننا الان ننظر
الى السؤال وهو كيف يبدو الامن في المنطقه
وكيف للولايات المتحده ان تقيم
وتثمن دعم الديمقراطيه
ودعم اداره وجهود تسير في الاتجاه السليم
خلافا او مقارنه بالابقاء على علاقه
محدوده تتعلق بالامن فقط وهذا بنايه الامر
سوف يؤدي الى انعدام الامن لبقيه الناس في
المنطقه وفي هذا البلد
تقول انها تبقي
خيار التدخل العسكري كملاذ اخير الولايات
المتحده تقول انها تدعم موقف اكواس اذا
حدث تدخل عسكري من اكواس كيف ستدعمه
الولايات المتحده وباي اليه
لان الولايات المتحده ستكون جاهزه لمساعده
النيجر ودول الاكواس لضمان ان نظام
الدستوري يتم المحافظه عليه هناك هل احد
دوافع هذا الموقف الامريكي هو القلق من
تمدد النفوذ الروسي في المنطقه
اعتقد ان روسيا لم تشارك في البدايه في
هذا الانقلاب ولكن هذه فرصه
لروسيا كحكومه وكمجموعه
فاجنر المرتزقه ان يشاركوا اكثر واكثر في
غرب افريقيا
هذان
الاحتمالان او الامكانات هما مقلقان
لنيجر وللمنطقه اذا في الولايات المتحده
لابد لها وان تكون قلقه بشان هذه الامور
كلها كان هناك حديث لقائد الانقلاب عبد
الرحمن تياني قبل قليل ودعا الى الحوار في
فتره اقصاها ثلاث سنوات ليكون هناك نظام
دستوري يختاره شعب النيجر هل مرحله
انتقاليه من هذا النوع يمكن ان تكون حلا
مناسبا للولايات المتحده
مرضيا للموقف الامريكي مما يحدث في النيجر
لا ادري ما هو الموقف من الحكومه
الامريكيه الان ولكن هذا لن يكون مقبولا
اولا
الانتخابات هي ما يدعو اليه الدستور
والشعب النيجري لديه هذا اذا لم يكن هناك
ازمه دستوريه في النيجر الى حين وقت تدخل
العسكر
وثانيا مرحله انتقاليه لثلاثه اعوام يبدو
بانها ثلاثه اعوام من التعليق والولايات
المتحده لن توافق على هذا لذلك يبدو
ربما بان المجموعه في النيجر تحاول ان
تقلد ما حدث في مالي ولكن الظروف مختلفه
تماما عن مالي لذلك لا ادري ان كانت
الولايات المتحده او الكونجرس سوف يكونون
قادرين على دعم هذا الامر وهذا التوجه
السفيره الامريكيه بيسا ويليام السفيره
الامريكيه السابقه في النيجر ونائبه مساعد
وزير الخارجيه الامريكي السابق للشؤون
الافريقيه شكرا جزيلا لك
وبهذا ينتهي الحصاد لهذه الليله شكرا لكم
وتصبحون على خير
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]